[Applause]
[Music]
buddy everybody what's going on welcome
to stream good today we're very excited
because Beth is back that's right Beth
is here everybody she's in the chat room
she's taking her questions she's banning
the haters yeah
haters get ready for the band the fan
fist
yeah and it's exciting takes were trying
out Facebook that's right - hello I call
it FB I call it my FB and mixer mixer
com ooh mixer dot-com hello mixer
dot-com oh you mean at four places God
darn it that's so many places that's
right uh guys I'm wearing my I can't get
sued for wearing a Superman shirt
Superman shirt today which is uh which
is that's not working at Facebook yet
but it will
I gotta play a game Ron now listen I'm
obsessed with this game called the
witness all right that knows it a lot I
have a million photos on my phone of
mazes and puzzles and all sorts of stuff
and so I heard this game rhyme was very
much like the witness only also like
Zelda breath of the wild which is
another amazing name uh Beth I think
you've played a lot of Zelda breath of
the wife you've seen a lot of it that's
right um so oh this is fun what's
happening here I must select a valid
profile which would be this one great uh
so glad you did that to me Ryan
someone said there's 60 puzzles in
Sinking data with rhyme ooh ooh is this
is a this might be the prettiest loading
screen I've ever seen in my whole life
uh is it a loading screen or is it a
puzzle you know what this looks like to
me is this looks like in the Dark Knight
Rises the prison that Bane is caught in
or yeah exactly you remember that you
guys saw the Dark Knight Rises right um
my facebook looks like it's working yeah
fantastic
we're on Facebook um yeah so this is
basically I think this game is just a
loading screen it's a loading screen of
the prison that no one could get out of
very beautiful it's so pretty it seems a
little mean to have a prison where you
know you can always see the sunlight a
log is letting screen a versus pJK
that's right um hello Rachel Felix
what's up um oh man I would love it uh
if the start so this is really exciting
I hope ever not an awesome weekend guys
today something really cool happened oh
and now it's loading superfast it heard
you and it's men and our morning meeting
today miss Sheryl Crow was our morning
meeting did you come to the morning
meeting oh yeah there you go you miss
Sheryl Crow
I feel like Sheryl Crow might have been
checking me out now wasn't wearing my
awesome super a man shirt is maybe
Cheryl's in the chat room into you look
I hope so Sheryl if you're in the chat
room were you checking me out and if so
call me um awesome hey do you mind
taking down that screen so I can see the
chat thanks pal
I do some alley creeper in the corner
creepin who I hope this game is quiet
and boring because there's no greater
game to stream at four places today
I know maybe call me and it's like that
is very calm very calming it's all right
look at these seas this is crazy this
like the beginning of Bioshock most
interesting loading screen in the entire
world ah
thug life speedy chicken always I'm more
of an ugly guy I like nuggets chicken
nuggets chicken McNuggets whoo now it's
like the beginning of Forrest Gump with
a feather here's the thing this thing
would never fly the rain would knock
this down into the oceans this is
already super unrealistic uh Zack we
have brought Jordan to comment before
I'm not going to do it today
I had a long walk with Jordan any walk
with Jordan is a long walk but a long
welcome to the commissary yesterday and
yeah we talked about Nashville it was a
very interesting tequila works baby
tequila
always works boo am i wearing a cape cuz
that's dope I want guys can we talk
about fashion for a second we talk about
fashion always I want capes to come back
as like a real form of thing that people
wear you know maybe there's a myth kind
of cape like I feel like women do wear
capes but they do we have
like what's the last time you saw a
woman in a cake not like that kind of
Cape but like it's called the Cape just
cuz it goes over your head in a cape
like commander Oh kind of like a poncho
like wearing yeah it's like wearing a
big blanket hey I can yell hey girl
crabs are king crabs hurt me what this
game can hurt me besides an
ex-girlfriend uh we got a lobster yeah
the conversation I had with Jordan was
really interesting we talked all about
barbecue and Nashville who I can do a
roll oh look at this crazy guys this
looks like a world is just like an
apocalyptic world all right
the crab tart and crab definitely was
either waving hello it's trying to fight
me for sure oh no it's digging so it
disappears man everything's hiding from
me he's yelling gonna be a big part of
this game comic-con thing is going well
touch of red just had a big meeting
about it
it's very scary it'll be fun they're
face huggers let's hope not beat music
let's hope not um all right so yeah
who's on the show today
today's show is our friend Nick Offerman
will be ah good old Nicky Offerman
nobody calls him Nick does he go by
Nicky I believe no and another young
lady from the mummy Annabelle Wallis
wait a Bella Wallis and mark Norman hey
Doc I heard a thing where uh
oh look at this look at this look at me
swimming around I heard a thing where
Tom Cruise you know he likes the guys
obsessed with doing his own stunts I
heard he did a thing where he made
there's a scene in a plane and he made
the crew shoot it like 64 times and
everybody threw up now is that here's a
question for the chat is that dedication
to craft or is that like pure insanity
and like you're a you remember that he's
like
right on a different level than anyone
else cuz he's probably like but does he
operate on a different level that's my
question is there another level to
operate on or is it just your being
stopped we got it do it sixty-four times
okay I skip reason go straight to rhyme
there is no reason there's only rhyme
people are saying you missed something
indicate I miss something a cave all
right wasn't the cave also there like I
said print button there's a totem up
there and our this belated there's a
totem as it was zero gravity shop does
that's medically intensive on your body
that's true upset druid droid you're
right I'm missing the cave in here what
is the thought that on the wall what is
the point of this game does anybody know
on the wall in this cave I don't see
in this cave rock with some sort of
writing on it it was on an upper ledge
upper light what can I jump over yeah an
upper ledge or maybe there's a wagon
they're talking about something oh well
we're back in the cave Oh over here oh
wait let's go over here maybe there are
caves over here do you think all right
here we go
oh maybe this is the cave they're
talking about oh here we go
wait there's something up here
oh I think we're offline right now
restart oh there we got yelled at it Oh
yelled at in and broke what the
now are we
they should rename this game climbing on
rocks because that's all it is I do I
will say I appreciate cool games I like
it this is the this is the conundrum ugh
normally in I like games that are cool
and epic but I hate starting games you
know yeah uh we're back everybody sorry
about that little technical difficulty
uh so far I found a vase and yelled at
it and it blew up so that's what's
happened that's all you've missed so far
uh perfect let's see here alright we got
a thing what is this so I guess I just
yell at stuff I yelled at now there's
butterflies I don't know ooh hey ooh I
got a seashell ooh
I think I'm playing a Celine Dion song
haha Rochelle crows oh and that's yeah
sure oh yeah every day is a winding road
and then it doesn't a thing and how
could you uh put the chat back up friend
put the chat back up for me thanks pal
um yes it's true someone said we didn't
pay our electric bill yeah exactly
they're shutting the power off they're
shutting the power off there was nothing
cool in the jug uh it just turned into a
bunch of dumb pieces not dumb pieces but
um being a look if this game is all
about blowing into conch shells I'm fine
with it it's you know guys we lead
stressful lives you know the day-to-day
everybody's on their phones all the time
just get a conch shell and blow into it
you know yeah that's your message is out
that way yeah get your messages out that
way oh I last night I tried to watch
that movie Elysium speaking of stressful
it's with Matt Damon it's by the guy who
did district 9 I wait to see that uh
first of all everybody talks into silly
accent Elysium is the opposite of this
this is beautiful and its nature you
know I mean I think the world is can go
to one of two places okay guys we're
gonna get Phyllis
the world can either go to like
disgusting technological Bladerunner e
Elysium thing or it can go to like
everything's destroyed and it's this
beautiful nature's taken back over you
know there's one or two things and but
Elysium everybody talks like they're
kind of French kind of I guess which was
weird and Matt Damon has a big like
robot suit on a robot frame I was fine I
don't know I didn't watch the end of it
kind of got boring I remember that movie
because I watched it in a movie theater
in Santa Monica or someone had vomited
so the whole time I was just thinking
about how it smelled like vomit that's
all I remember
Oh Elysium vomit Elysium not like vomit
to me exactly uh where do I go should we
try to like get in that big Tower I feel
like they want us to go up in the tow
alright let's figure out where we're
going here can I jump from here into the
water will I survive is the question
maybe it's like if it is like Zelda you
have one of those and you have o big
parachute guys do I try to jump off the
thing I'm doing it
oh oh oh yeah there we go hey Lela
that's cool that's great and a hundred
thousand years
hey O'Malley would you mind putting that
I'm sorry man sorry I see thanks pal
uh-huh see theirs will be in a new ice
age and nothing can stop it I don't know
I think global warming might stop that
pretty quickly Oh guys I'm gonna die I'm
gonna drown how do I go back up can I
get to the surface I don't want to dive
anymore oh my god I just drowned I'm
back that sucked
alright let's figure let's see where we
got to go here yeah breathing underwater
boy yeah thanks spoiler alert
uh okay we got the conch shell where do
we think we go who's played this game
you got a cape of course you should jump
off of things exactly I agree this one
feel this one feels broken here over
there DEFCON one lumbers ACK exactly oh
my god it's getting dark it gets dark in
this game
that means there's monsters guys not a
fan of monsters go here maybe should we
try along going home the coast
ah this game I would imagine ed wink
this game hey Rob revenge I'd imagine
this game is available on PC aren't most
games available on PC someone said go
towards the tree go towards the trees
I'm surrounded by trees what you going
tired
yeah go towards all the trees go towards
the trees alright where the trees are
the trees are over there let's go
towards the trees I'm jumping off again
it's swimming around I know those
nothing it's fun uh Deb this game is
called rhyme I've been told it's an
adventure puzzler that's right it's
supposed to be like Zelda meets the
witness and the witness I love and Zelda
I was okay I almost hit that rock that
was bad
alright let's figure out how to go up
how do I surface I just hold a why did I
die before that was done alright I'm not
comfortable with oh if there's like
jellyfish now you can't I see they don't
want you to go this way alright fair
enough
so so far this game we've learned you
can break oh my god these jellyfish are
being dicks
alright okay look at this man you know
I'm not a fan of that let me if you're
gonna make an open-world game make it
open world you know yeah don't just have
jellyfish do your dirty work
hey Singapore hey ha ha 4 4 5 6 davila
wants teams's Gingras there you go well
it's dark and I'm back to where I
started I don't have any lights
so maybe the screens just gonna go
completely black make it swim over to
this thing let's go this way I do like
this person gets in the water how I get
in the water which is like you run with
your knees high
uh ooh I love that control at four there
we go
what's up hogfish sniper hogfish sniper
Humphry sniper tell me the best way to
snipe a hogfish what's the best way it
is really dark and I'm in the water and
I'm scared and I bet to see the
jellyfisher keeping me from going this
way
dude it's come on there's all let's not
be afraid of jellyfish ain't gonna fall
for what I think you'll fall for it I
don't have a control F for playing on
xbox so don't be upset I'm upset all the
time about everything well here's the
deal says hogfish sniper oh man can kill
this guy kill this dude which game that
dude right there time to put the ban
fist on oh I love a good band fist see
you later
I mean we won't miss you
I bet others will come and take your
place I'm sure they will guys it's dark
I'm a little scared I do have a cape I
won't say my stance though here's my
stance at video games I makes me
uncomfortable having a flash licks I
just feel like you're a target you know
I kind of play by 28 days later rules
which is like zombies can see you all
the time even if there's no zombies in
the game so I'd rather kind of run
around to the dark anyway hey wait
there's like things up here
others birds can I get up here nope nope
nope perfect
I'm not sure if there's a story trooper
we woke up ah oh wait there was a storm
in the beginning our cape was flying
around basically in a storm I think
right and then we got then we washed up
on the shore of this mysterious island
with all these stars though oh cool we
can see galaxies up there so it does
look like kind of the Milky Way I can
call out the vines this clamp it oh
really it's kind of too dark to see knee
vines it's this just gonna be this
entire game just me running around on
the beach because that's what it feels
like it is very calmly hogfish sniper I
love it there we go what is a hogfish
what does a hot fish taste like cuz you
know for instance not all fish taste
like fish shark tastes like chicken like
a porky fish
it's a it's a bacon fish I do love me
some delicious bacon fish well it's
super dark and I can't see
delicious all right favorite type of
game like first-person shooter or what
ah you know what I love a game I don't
have a specific genre I like the best
but I will say I like a game that shows
me stuff I've never seen before
so if that's a side scroller like Fez
was really cool because that was a game
where you changed things from 2d to 3d
and solve puzzles again I've said braid
is really cool the Last of Us was
amazing cuz the storytelling was
incredible um so yeah I kind of just
like things like where you see things
you've never seen Katamari Damacy was
really fun um we're yeah we're it's like
a new idea or new you know or just a
really great storytelling I got a chance
to play which I three I played we did
what your three for a gamer which is
really fun and when I do games for gamer
it ruins it for me because I basically
play the entire game or as much of it as
I can
and if we're working with the developer
like we did for Witcher 3 I basically
play the end of the game so I'll play it
through the end
which is great so yeah so I know a ton I
just done deaf count too so it kind of
ruins it for me which sucks which is why
like I really want to do a gamer for
like Red Dead Redemption to like The
Last of Us - but I love those games and
I kind of don't want to do gamers for
them because then they'll be ruined for
me forever uh which sucks all right we
got to figure out a way to go
who knows hot where to go here come on
Chad help me out what's that he beaters
frozen yeah what a day what a day uh I
think maybe this way let's go try this
way wait maybe I can let's see if I can
kind of get on the thing and go over to
the right maybe should I do this Koen
Conan ruins games gardeners are ruining
it's just that you know it all it is is
I just since I have to know everything
about the game in that way since I have
to know everything about the game then
it's like it ruins it for me because
then I know everything about the game
I'm like I don't think we're going to e3
this year um but I will be my allowed to
say that thing we're doing next Friday I
don't know okay well I'll be doing
something cool next Friday which will be
fun um yeah but no we're shooting to
gamers next week uh we planned all the
platforms trooper we plan all of them I
would love to have nor McDonald on
series generic that would be amazing
um yeah jibber jabber what's this
there's there something up here jibber
jabbers are tough just because of
scheduling shout out to ty Segall
hush-hush company secrets
oh boy here we go pcs the best but guys
there's no thing that's better than
another thing what like it's all the
platform's have their have their uh have
their ups and their downs what the hell
man where do I go anybody know
are we just done up here is this setup
going to be back soon I don't know if
that means
what's up captain quasar everybody go
here I'm at a loss guys who's played the
runt who's played Ryan n64 is great
William I think you should go we were
before we put out okay great we played
some bond an n64 on here before I guess
do I jump back down we did I will say we
did
alright now I'm on this thing this is
exciting this game is very pretty
I want it to be daylight again because I
cool died so we can't go in the water
because the jellyfish have stopped us
this game is very pretty
is it true there's no dialogue in this
game Zeki pinky that's other witnesses
hey Nina rata spread your wings and fly
ah ma shy marshal I don't think today I
miss him on top of the hill where the
vines and for 10 min for those goddamn
vines
who's upset that vine is dead anybody
all the people at put computer working
in vines vine stars are upset about nine
stars I love the fact that we're vine
stars at one point there lives a white
thing everything is up tops is tanker
you mean not alot ok don't need to be
sarcastic the water is fun water is fun
I like this women in the ground all
right back up top then we're getting
really good at climbing this rock
actually I should be better at climbing
this one rock it's kind of rising also
that game journey you guys aren't
playing journey we're like a ghost in
the desert running around it's pretty
cool this game would be great if it had
a sprint capability alright we're going
back up the vines RV why do I get wet
life unfold and sprint please got the
destination it's about the journey
you know in a stream it's a little bit
about the destination you can't just not
all right guys is getting a light again
I'm getting happier where the F are
these vines I keep hearing so much about
I don't see any vines you see any vines
anywhere where the vines people find our
texture on a cliff texture on a cliff
alright let's look at some cliffs
friends are where the weird high rocks
in the jellyfish word the weird high
rocks and the jellyfish this is what
Bianca I miss I believe you Bianca I'm
just looking I'm looking for the high
rocks the weird high rocks and the cliff
like down there that's kelp though weird
are I could see the jellyfish there's
jump jellyfish are my enemy by the way I
hate jellyfish alright the jellyfish are
over there
it's up Qabalah believe gobble wobbly
turn to the right
alright this game takes weeks to finish
do remor remotes we're trying con
Alucard - Ascona punch ah kona punches
me I haven't seen coloring actually a
couple days I haven't talked to him
haven't talked to him since brick I
haven't talked to had
that's not true cuz he had a bunch of
underwear delivered him and then he was
uh he got it he opened a package of
underwear and then he was like doing
bits with the underwear
ah that was last week we was last week
I'd week off yeah so is the week before
last I haven't talked to Kona in two
weeks I just backed out slowly and
laughs nervously as he was doing his
underwear bits I probably shouldn't say
that on a live stream but you know what
I just said it guys that's for the
people on mixer today mixer and Facebook
you get you get great behind-the-scenes
stories about underwear bits all right
what about over here is this like a vine
situation
oh no that's a vine situation I'm
looking around for some vines what could
possibly be a vine step first question
for developers why didn't you make the
vines more obvious in this game I know I
don't think there are any vines up here
right but I can tell you Red Dead
Redemption undead on my stream yeah for
sure I just set up a whole streaming
area in my kitchen guys it's dope ah
yeah my own stream I'm playing I'm
playing through Red Dead Redemption the
undead DLC and it's fun there's zombie
bears I just murdered like 19,000
zombies the last time I got a flaming
horse what pretty dope yeah you get all
the four horse of the horses of the
Apocalypse
I think when you get the death one
somebody said if you run into a zombie
their head just explodes right now if I
run into a zombie they light on fire
it's pretty great it's the opposite of
this game okay what's happening here all
right guys it's daytime we got to make
the most of this I don't see any effing
vines
I do see those dumb jellyfish that I
hate vines are the white ledges I kept
jumping up on what Mary otter because
I've I live in a small apartment I know
their place to put it okay
the vines were the things like I'm
jumping up on
these things those are vines
I see so those tell me where I can jump
up on things this game is very confusing
this is not a vine this looks like a it
looks like a drunk college girl who
puked on a building you know she ate too
much Greek yogurt drink too many mics
hard lemonade's and threw up on the book
that's what that looks like to me that's
not a vine I'm sorry hate to be a jerk
about it they're a little thick bird
food that's what the unicorn there's a
unicorn already a bird poop splatter yes
that's exactly puke not a vine
I agree Brooke Chapman not a vine uh no
it's not I really am a terrible gamer
thank you I appreciate when people come
into the chat just to be jerks that
always makes me happy it's like yep
there's still are jerks out there as
nice as people are in the world you know
there still are jerks okay we're gonna
find some vines not oh there's a cool
lizard a couple lizards can I yell at
those lizards Hey hey girl alright let's
go back
I see so basically the the sorority girl
puke tells me where I can jump up on I
can only jump up on see oh I see so
every sorority girl puke area like here
that shows me I can jump up on there
okay interesting okay that's good to
know now we know armed with this puke
knowledge we know now where to go so
let's run around to see if we can find
more puke places I don't know tanker I
don't I've only I've only used one conch
shell it's all I've found so far
one conch
guess we just gotta walk around are
there more should we go underwater I'm
afraid to go underwater excite drowned
once it amazes me you haven't figured
out the puke knowledge sooner well you
know what I'm sorry it was dark for half
of this game so far how are you good how
am I supposed to know I don't normally
think oh when I see puke on a Ledge
let's put my hands on it and jump up
there great idea bleh it's not where my
mind normally goes all right let's go
over you know what we haven't really
explored this side over here let's go
over here see if there's any puke ledges
over here oh you know what hey look at
this I think there's a hole in there
area we haven't looked at oh we did look
at this area but it was nighttime but
now we can see the puke ledges so we can
get up on it I have to show I didn't
know what I did activate one totem is
the totem the vase that I blew up by
yelling at it oh here we go here the
vines now see these are vines this is
what I'm talking about yeah that's a
vine here we go all right guys we
climbed it the vine and your vine yeah
your vines your oh great we got out of
the first area it only took us a half
hour ooh look at that big thing
cool guys is we're in Alicia oh this is
cool
oh this is pretty cool we got little
what was that a Bonnie I I don't know it
is that it it looks a little pig looks
like a hog fish honestly this kid is
kind of a dick I'm gonna be honest and
it's a little pig deer thing it's okay I
think it's a mixed being a deer in a pig
are we on earth that's a good question
I don't know guys are we on earth are we
on dreamscapes yeah we ended our
nightmare
we'll leave this yeah it's a Jeff Koons
statue now maybe we get our key
yeah yeah now we have the powers of a
corgi we're really fast
look at me Hey look I could dance
boop-boop boop-boop boop-boop all right
okay all right we yelled it a corgi can
I catch that thing
I'm kind of running all weird all of a
sudden maybe I'm like triangle I might
be chafing might be a lot of chafing
going on in this little suit of mine you
know oh hey thanks Keaton appreciate it
good night forgot me turn off ray yeah
we got we got a new Xbox looks like I
forgot to turn off the notifications
well that's fun everyone
your friend your friend says can I yell
it I'm singing wait ooh
squinting Fox statue well I yelled it
all right so far we yelled at some stuff
we're singing a song you know I'm down
I'm still down for this game it's pretty
cool I'm here for it I do play overwatch
I'm terrible at it I don't ever rank
it's my I don't know it's I'm bad I play
Winston and you're never supposed to
play Winston right Winston's for noobs
Winston's the gorilla by the way who has
a dope gun but it's not very powerful
but yeah we played overwatch with Peter
Dinklage and Lena Headey Game of Thrones
which is awesome and by the way guys
Game of Thrones the new season right
yeah soon I think when is it July and no
June no July August September - I just
named all the months Tipu an icon flash
overwatch is a place where you can go
yeah you should go over what watch it
over and over watch it over and over
again Oh puke ledge here we go
Buechel edge let's go puke ledge July 7
I've not played hyper light drifter
should I up thanks Keaton what's up all
right thanks Keaton July 16 oh wait now
I sing before I was like ah and now I
sing hey wait I've seen you let's get
more and more melodious as game yeah
maybe I just learned a whole song hey
look at these weird beams of light guys
should we go over there and figure that
out I always follow the light follow the
light run towards the light oh boy I
think kind of made a joke one time
that's what he yells it uh it's grandpa
run towards the light up here we go
that's what this today is just gonna be
all new friends all new friends what
about if we stop playing again we just
start messaging all of our friends who
hears something do I yell at it I can't
yell at it oh wait let's get up here and
yell at this thing
so far there have been exactly zero
puzzles I just want to point that out
okay also you know what follow your own
rules games like I should be able to get
up on this thing look I could clearly
jump up and grab it you know what I hate
it when games don't follow their own
rules like don't do this also by the way
if it's an open-world game don't have
jellyfish blocking my path it's
like thin yeah exactly everyone you
couldn't like put furniture in like a
diagonals all right yes it's like they
fix that now oh there you go but it's
like I hate yeah it's like follow the
rules you can do anything as long as we
say it's okay like no you're gonna make
an open-world game make it open-world
the whole game puzzles me yes that's
true don't go chasing waterfalls
hahahahaha
thank you snail why is this stream
happening I don't know man why is your
life happening why does anything happen
you know that's a pretty deep question
I'll say you know what I think the
stream is happening because billions of
years ago amino acid chains combined in
a shallow pool on a rocky planet that
will name Tara three three planets away
from a star named Sol then after a long
time
kind of like bacteria formed right in a
pool in that same pool and kind of did
this bacteria thing and then later
bacteria kind of formed more complex
organisms and you know what one of the
organisms decided to go on land and then
you know it's been a little time on the
land and then a couple organisms went on
the land and then their plants and then
in a bunch of lives organisms eat plants
and then billions of years later there
were dinosaurs and then later there were
humans and then you know humans got it
got together they started making tools
and I you know procreating a quarry and
they took over started mastering their
own environment and I kind of took over
the planet and then you know thousands
of years later there was an Industrial
Revolution where you know we created
machines and then using those machines
we refined them and
and a better way to compute numbers and
things and so a couple of smart people
got together and made these giant things
they call computers in huge rooms
they're using punch cards and you know
like on the invitation game right then
there were a couple of wars and a bunch
of crazy should happen and then this
dude Nintendo made a video game system
oh wait we're not playing in Tendo then
Bill Gates was born and he cut founded
this company a lot of these other people
called Microsoft and they created a
sinkhole and Xbox and then somebody made
this game to go on the Xbox and then
separately other people came up with
live streaming technology and we put
those two things together and that's how
the stream happens that's why this dream
is happening to answer your question but
it all started with those amino acid
chains really that does not amused
history I just I feel like I learned so
much yeah
there is a great uh there's a great
YouTube video what is it called I put it
on I put on my Facebook page it's like
everything's kind of happening dude or
whatever that's like the history of the
world this guy what is it it's really
really funny all right I want to get
over there onto that thing and yet I
want to yell at that thing can I do it
from here probably not what is it oh now
I see I forgot much less threatening
alrighty
yeah he's kinda just like mm I'm sorry
we can't return this Power Wheels to
target you need a receipt mm history of
the world is machine man oh thanks
I collect her I appreciate that it's
nice to be you say yeah the history yeah
it's like the history of the world in 15
minutes or something all right let's go
let's explore another area he's look
weirdly roaming like a Roman aqueduct or
something whoa
no history of the entire world I get I
guess that's what it is
guys you gotta watch this video and
stuff Andy mutts any months this is the
entire world I guess it's really funny
definitely definitely worth the time
it's super great Clampett yes I forgot
that part uh fresh brew I think the
point of this game I would say
exploration it's also supposed to be a
puzzler
well you know what when I'm oh I guess
it's contextual so if I'm near something
that I sing verses uh that look like a
hog fish I was to the point of this game
is exploration so far and figuring out
puzzles I mean I like this game it's
really cool it's very calming there's a
bunch of cool animals eating see you
look they're like deer pigs or something
I think I don't want to I unfortunately
I can't sing near the animals or else I
would uh yeah history the entire world I
guess you guys got to watch that video
it's so funny oh sorry
uh water melt watermelon boy thank you
for helping us you were hashtag first
mate first dude hashtag first maybe
what's happening here can I sing at
these thing whoo
cool Oh all this Hey look at this
ah interesting
so c-can I get them to follow me
somewhere I'm a terrible thrower can I
jump on these creatures I don't mean it
in a bad way I'm just wondering if I can
like use them to get up on a place oh I
guess not
hmm you think I want to do here oh my
god oh people want you to bring them off
the cliff
that's so mean throw them off the cliff
you just like make them jump off a cliff
oh oh geez oh just like that thing in
the Bible really oh you know what wait
I'm gonna get him over here oh wait I'm
gonna get my new friends to scare this
dude away watch this it's gonna be cool
safety in numbers guys ah no AI collect
her sorry we just do it for fun man you
know you don't need your money we're
doing it to entertain all right this way
guys everybody follow me
we're gonna get rid of this dumb hog
come on where's our other hog friend I
made I scare him away
all right come on let's go this way guys
hey guys yo guys I got a big orange here
nobody wants this orange why is the big
oh you know what maybe I just go and
throw it in this guy here we go this guy
is gonna be it's enticing any one of
these they said take the fruit across
the bridge bridge
later sucker hey the big one in orange
oh yeah here we go uh time to yell at
this Corgi I think we freed the soul of
the Corgi be free Corgi be free my core
agenda oh wait a second oh I see look
and we lit the thing the core you down
there so I guess we got to free all the
Corgi Souls I see so this game is
basically a bunch of corgis have been
imprisoned by a terrible demon a corgi
hating demon and we have to free them
[Music]
that sweet roll I just did dope whoa
seagulls I will say now that we're over
here it's much much brighter over here
it's kind of scary down by the beach you
know all right let's go over here well
let's just walk the mega quarry and
unlock them mega Corky mega Corgi
activated today's final boss is like oh
yeah exactly
final buzzer giant quarry I wonder uh
this game is kind of like Voltron but
with corgis I kind of think you know why
in this game called rhyme that's a great
question that is a good bit like I'm
looking at hello done more research
there we go no one 30 or 100 whatever we
want to do it's the work
interesting wait how many corgis were
here before I don't maybe we didn't know
oh here we go now we now we yell at the
Corgi we unfroze the Corgi Orion more
reason Oh Oh see yeah we're unlocking
the mega Corgi so really we only got two
more corgis to go pretty great we got
some fruit over here I just want to feed
these dudes they're kind of hungry you
know come some food uh put the rhyme in
the coconut okay boy did they say they
said Cory you nut Corgi not given s in
case are you with the Riley
yes captain queers are you free s please
free s is Maurice The Rime of the
Ancient Mariner what's that it's like a
song just rhyming song cosmic Corgi um
let's go find some of the corgis man
if I any cronut know what is a Corona
Corona it's a croissant that they made
into deep-fried croissant
it's a cronut that's it I mean a
croissant it's a doughnut what is the
difference between a doughnut and a
croissant it's deep they're both ones
big course on is like layers and layers
of like butter and oh yeah though I only
know that from Greek fish making show oh
great baking shows Ilana croissant
this is dive this is surface uh hard to
see the puke
when it's dark oh brother oh boy god
save lazy thanks for the add mmm how do
i what if I wanted to but how do I
all right let's search for some cracks
and meet the ground these all barnacles
what's going on here no offense we know
what I also appreciate in games is like
a an oxygen bar I'm gonna be honest with
you what if I try to sing underwater am
I gonna drown nope
I just can't do it oh just smash my face
in ah guys I was at a pool a few months
ago
and I was trying to do a thing where I
was swimming across the pool with your
you know you look if you're like me and
you're an idiot you try to hold your
breath and see if you can go across the
pool and I smashed I went like this
right before I hit the thing and I gave
myself a huge bruise on my forehead
croissant is a luxury Hisle luxury well
how do we get up on this thing do we
dive down and then come up oh we can go
underneath there we go grab eggs are
really awesome your grabbers are great
this is good night ah puke ledge here we
go I knew we'd find a puke ledge we
worked hard enough
yeah Corgi time whoo
be free Corgi be free ooh
what the edges of the screen indicate
you're likeable what what edges I don't
believe you see that I'm just gonna stay
under here till I see what you're
talking about
oh I see oh I see I see got it hey
grapefruit dad new friends new friends
you know just gotta lean into the new
friends thing been doing out of the
beach Corgi it's nighttime we're gonna
eat my Corgi Hunter it's not really a
bar that's true special effects
I'm glad the corgis made Steph they're
statues well the corgis have tiny little
legs ironic I know Oh goddamn it I'm
gonna uh senator everyone my favorite
queasy video please everybody click on
best favorite Corgi vignette she's
wearing been working hard and she needs
up she needs everybody to enjoy these
oh whoops sorry everybody no emotes
sorry Piper Beth that's what we're good
at is disappointing people clearly yeah
oh dude we're about to unlock Megan
Corgi wait how do we do it where's the
last Corgi oh it's over here all right
we're kinda getting the hang of this
game it's pretty fun I will say guys if
you like puzzlers I'm super into the
witness right now I've been playing it
no joke I've been playing it probably
for weeks
I put hundreds of hours in that game
I've got on my phone this is crazy
I'm gonna show you guys some photos on
my phone here while I'm running see I'm
running with one hand guys it's called
multitasking everybody wait how do I
because you have to kind of remember
things in the witness you have to
remember all these different places to
go so I've just been taking photos of
like mazes to like remember stuff it's
it's making me crazy if you look at my
phone look at this there's there's just
hundreds of photos amazes this is crazy
just mazed oh wait that's a receipt from
Ikea maze after maze after maze after
maze
after maze after maze after maze after
maze it's nuts that's what I do with my
life instead of going on talking to
people I go home and play mazes ancient
court oh this is not an ancient Corgi
graveyard no guys we've done this this
is where you found the vine so we're not
going back down what was the Corgi video
oh it was a my dog you're corny but I
don't hear but like at home and message
okay I was gonna say what's your corgis
name Daisy Daisy whoa hands back legs
she's half calf Corgi half machine she's
kind of like Terminator of corgis yeah
she's a coordinator that's dope
yeah it's pretty nerdy Hedwig ah but
again it's super fun all right where are
we going oh this way sorry that Corgi oh
I think you're making people weep with
me what happiness he's very happy with
their wheels huh
Oh Ivan as a Corgi Ivan what's your
corgis name wait wait I guess we do have
to go this way I'm just really happy
that I've made this dream be locally
yeah Corgi stream 2017
hey thanks hogfish I'm gonna have a hog
fish one of these days that's my pledge
to you more machine than dog more cute
machine in dog up thanks the jam and Ja
thanks for the ad I got to get over how
do we get over to that area guys jump in
the water again I feel like the
jellyfish are gonna be dicks to me Oh
Ryder is a good Corgi name never play
the chord you want steers later BAM yeah
I'm sure see here played with a Corgi
all right it's not Ernie gross guys and
it's a few little futile to say to a
chat the only solution is to sing where
do I sing windsock how do I get way over
there all right I'm gonna try swimming
but I have a really bad feeling that the
jellyfish are just gonna be dicks to me
countdown to jellyfish here it is I knew
it I knew it
ah man can I go this way
nope can I go this way
nope oh God I sing from my heart
what do you mean captain quasars
allergic to dodge that sucks
ooh look at this Daisy Daisy she had a
chariot costume for Halloween Oh with a
tiny doll right that's awesome dude what
about a bend her costume Oh she'll be in
New York probably she came to New York
oh my god can you bring her to the show
yeah
hey low bass man huh I think Daisy needs
like a little like gladiator costume
like a warhorse yeah like helmet or you
could go like battle cat and he-man like
spray it you want spray paint
Daisy Green do you know oh darn it
maybe there's an industrial salmon farm
nearby that causes the jellyfish to
appear that's very specific but possible
yeah that's true Fox 7 starve a shark
costume eating a dog that is interesting
that's what I like that I enjoy when dog
costumes are like I don't know where it
looks like there's hate things more
battle where it's a like a thing riding
of the dog or something or the dog is
like a little person yeah yeah like that
or where what is that one that I always
see where's like two guys carrying yes
that's good okay how do we get to this
last Corgi it's gonna be like breath of
the wild where it's like you have to do
one simple thing but it actually takes
90% of the game to do like what you
think is a simple thing we got to go
that way we have to get I mean we have
to go in the water at some point right
keep going up the hill okay I'm up the
hill Corgi for next president dude
hi okay here we go we have to go back
all right I'm gonna try jumping in the
water and swimming but we all know that
what's going to happen
also I'm sure there's more to this game
than just this little part of the island
right so we haven't really opened up the
whole game
[Music]
all right here oh I see we need to get
up there I see we got to get up there to
run and jump across
I see okay so we got to get up there so
we got to figure that out
all right fair enough dogs Halloween
costume is use a horse from headless
Horseman's there's a little saddle and a
headless horseman attached that's
amazing I love that thanks John you're
the best hello Travis fire I hope I hope
you're the Travis in our office cuz that
would make Travis cool
Travis cool get back to work Travis
bastard
um guys were super pumped about Comic
Con this year we got a lot of really fun
stuff planned yeah so like a month and
half away but what that half away we're
working every day like it's happening
tomorrow that's right yes we are that's
true that's for us it kind of is we got
to get up here is when we get up how do
we get up here there a map where you
press pause or something that's a good
question and would be helpful there was
like oh this is some this is a very
calming oh I love this pause screen what
up what a nice place to rest
Oh guys let's just hang out for here in
this posturing for a minute
let's look I was turning this out orders
of core uses it oh yeah whoo right
everybody just take a minute just take
him off your stressful day oh this is
great I I might download this music and
just have it playing all the time I
think there any royalty-free quick Corgi
videos we can just put up I was just
gonna send the war of mine oh I do yeah
can you put can you put a rolling can
you put a quirky video picture recording
it oh here's a video here's a photo of
Daisy taking a nap send it to us
sent it to omalley maybe you can put it
up in this room we're gonna keep playing
but when it's ready we're gonna take
guys we're gonna take a sweet Corgi
break and a few minutes oh here we go
we're finding out what's up now
ooh how do I jump over this way nervous
yeah guys we're gonna take a sweet Corgi
break everybody get ready everybody
think about things that are worrying you
think about the stress you had in your
day oh here we go look at this
not sure what's happening here this is a
Corgi by the way look at that that's a
little tiny Corgi
[Music]
pups I just want a circle do
but
maybe we go this way look at this Beth
what is this the glowing Corgi oh my
goodness it literally is accordion oh
yeah just looked at the tail well some
Cory's do have long tails I think that
is a race between a Pembroke and a Welsh
really oh my gosh dude the tails I love
it I think we can run up wait I think we
can run up over here that's not a way to
do it
uh yeah look all these vomit legends for
finding so many
can I jump over there okay I can get up
here
like stop lying for views yeah no it's
not a fuss I'm so glad that they
actually put in real vines because I was
getting upset for this fake vine
if it was ain't got some Lord
croft action going yeah this is very
lower off T Lara Croft's Lara Lara
all right cross this game just a book
for you yes dude yes it is it actually
is about corgis guys oh nice O'Malley
oh whoa what's up oh oh I don't know
what maybe it's future me is this game
we gonna get super weird in a second in
a second he says there's no railing here
and this is kind of a safety hazard I
hope these people are rot isn't worried
about getting sued by CI Oh
unlock that last Corgi
ooh music just got dub
what happened how come I can't see
anything all right
oh man oh yeah okay don't fall
the music is very dramatic right now
this game I'm gonna make me cry at some
point cuz I feel like there's tears
coming on oh yeah very like almost Lord
of the Rings music yeah it does son
right Lord of the Rings II uh go hear
this one not I'm up here I don't really
want to go back down I feel like there's
something over there too mm I should go
this way now going the wrong way
oh no oh no what oh no what oh no we're
dead we're dead we're dead
we're dead guys I think it's time we
take a quick corgi break oh you know
what heaven is heaven is Gordon heaven
is Cory's guys everybody think about
your worries and troubles ready for a
corgi break here we go oh yeah get ready
for this oh yeah oh this is great oh man
sweet Cory's yep
I feel sleepy this is amazing oh yeah
what a star she's a star now that's
right
look at his little white socks girl yes
you nice cool socks
uh-huh my favorite day oh god I want
this to be like just my entire life I
found the meaning of life because this
Corgi break so cute real quirky nothing
but corgis Corgi power super Sayan Corgi
all right let's go back we're get we'll
go back we'll go back to we're gonna get
back to uh guys when it gets too
stressful because the pause music is so
great in this game we're just gonna have
a corgi break I mean I have another
photo oh yeah sure you know to our next
Corgi break that was awesome
where am I going I'm supposed to be
going up here
[Music]
corgi break guys never forget the power
of the Corgi what's this I can go up on
this thing oh shoot uh what if I can get
up there somehow
it pushes
that is a real Corgi that's uh yeah I
got unlock the mega Courtney now that's
Beth's Corgi ooh can I get over there so
no Conan would punch the out of you
we found a wheeze the stream to make
quick yeah no kidding
so don't tell him guys next time you see
Conan thanks Elon next time you see one
month yeah
Elon was next time you see Conan don't
tell him what we're doing with the
stream which is just using it as an
excuse to show beautiful beautiful
corgis
laughs you can go up here this is kind
of cool I do love the exploration aspect
of this game is really fun
oh look found something else what is
this it's a piece of pie I don't
understand those little those things I
will say that but I like if we I guess
we yell at it that's a cool thing
[Music]
I could have just come this way which is
a thousand times easier than the other
way I came
ah Steve I I'm my pd3 very briefly but
Conan won't be there golden chew toy
that's what it is oh yeah
doesn't your right those make those
probably our signposts that's true
Oh guys we're about to unlock the mega
Corgi who's excitedly its excited yeah
oh wow hey oh it's a fox ha ha ha that's
just pretend it just kills us it bites
our throw whoa ah oh man we had the Fox
but I got taken away from us what oh
wait this is cool all right is the
coolest escalator I've ever seen again
though no railing so it is a little
dangerous
I believe that Corgi turned into a bog
yeah that was definitely a biggest plot
twist to this game so far
there sure was a corgi but then it's a
we're just gonna pretend it's a
long-tailed Corgi yeah now there's a
weird baby thing
Oh are we going into my baby land the
Cardigan Welsh Corgis long tail as
opposed to a Pembroke are they are there
any Court
corgis that have long fur any Longford
corgis their fur gets great long as we
don't trim like a shaggy
is there a shag Corgi a shaggy as I call
it I just say hmm what about like a
bratty teenager all of a sudden there's
the tutorial yeah I bet
oh my god you're just gonna yell at me
the whole time dude all right
uh can I push this thing or something
what am I supposed to do here can I roll
up the thing nope oh my god that's a
great picture oh wait I can yell at this
thing whoa alright so things affect
other things too bad I can't sprint but
whatever Oh God
and I'm really just gonna pretend this
is a corgi it's a wild animal dude don't
go petting wild animals what are you
doing you guys just wait for what's
coming oh yeah looks like car just
attacks us
it does hello
[Music]
I mean music a plus with the desert oh
my god
what are these babies oh I got a do
we're all three a little food y'all
three of it one source on
oh I see
I need to get all three of them somehow
there we go got it all right
alright we got it guys we're figuring
stuff out here we're not totally stupid
I mean I am but well there's a big crazy
tower who would build a skyscraper right
here like a jerk you know what's
interesting is in kawaii one of the
islands of Hawaii they can't build a
buildings more than four stories tall
that dough I do this or something
[Music]
cool
this is all this is kind of like the
witness this is cool booyah the red fox
is Conan I actually like to call Conan
the rooster not the room Fox he's more
of a honestly personality is more like a
rooster than a fox let's be honest here
- more like a weird bird uh okay what's
the deal here kids do I jump down the
giant pit it's probably a bad idea
they're blazing the witness everywhere I
am I know what's weird is like I will
see like I'll be out and like I'll see a
weird circle thing about who that could
be amazed that's a real thing we talked
about this how like one did you get
really into Tetris you like see like
look down at tile and like yeah or our
background by the way which is this is
totally Tetris II but ya know that's
absolutely true I remember the first
time I played Tetris I had dreams about
Tetris like crazy Tetris dream and the
first time a kid I worked at Kmart I'd
dreams about stocking shelves again I
still have those dreams this is just a
way for me to get back into working at
camera guys um I think sever another
Corgi break right again like I have to
say the pause music in this game is the
most calming thing ever and if you're
just joining us
Beth has donated some of her photos of
her awesome dog Daisy awesome I see you
later for Lifan exactly so enjoy this
sweet Cory everybody take a moment think
about something stressing you out and
enjoy this quick Corgi break also it
looks like an immemorial segment so
hopefully wrote that she's alive - I
know well it's called the tetris effect
let's go
[Music]
oh this is amazing this might be the
greatest thing we've ever done ever
where DC just has white paws yeah that's
awesome
she's the way belly dude that's my
favorite photo much fun everyone
receipts by the window yeah this is
we're literally just doing this for
ourselves yeah big frosty O'Malley for
putting this pretty this beautiful
thanks tech guy we love you alright
ready let's go back he think you should
physically be on the street yes I know
alright that was a great that was one of
my favorite Corgi break so far guys we
only have 50 more minutes so if you have
any any Corgi questions you want to ask
Beth now's the time how old is Elvis
Daisy she is going to be 14 or 15 whoa
holy Moses she doesn't have use of her
back legs
and how long has it been said she had
back legs uh maybe two years wait if she
doesn't have them on she can kind of
move around like a mermaid oh yeah sure
that's good like fly her out here it's a
business yeah right exactly
she's you'd be in first class with us
can you bring her comic-con Lady Mary
can you bring her to comic-con do you
think what's her favorite snack
she likes cheese if you say cheese she
gets really oh my god so it's hard to
take a photo around her yeah it's
alright and it's hard to tell us apart
too because we both do the same thing I
was gonna say it is weird sometimes I do
feel like I'm working with a corgi
[Music]
I was like oh uh huh huh huh hey what do
you think about Comey testifying on
Thursday huh hey yeah what do you how do
you feel about us get into policy yeah
what are you doing what are you doing
this weekend you're really excited to
see alien covenant what did you think I
know what you think of the end of
Prometheus hello I did see Gardens
galaxy too and I loved it I have to go
see uh who did you Wonder Woman tonight
oh I guess II wonder one that looks
awesome paging we just booked up hey how
did Jenkins Jenkins per Thursday patty
Jenkins other movie monster with
Charlize Theron awesome movie not a
feel-good movie it's the opposite of the
quirky break motto it's like it's about
that serial killer and but Charlize
Theron is amazing Christina Ricci's
amazing it was a really really great
movie but a tough movie to watch but
very good I'll be a patty Jenkins man
Wonder Woman super excited for one of
them we did an awesome gal gadot remote
where conan tries to get trained to be
Wonder Woman um spoiler alert he's not
successful bad it's bad not athletic he
did ride a mechanical bull though it's
pretty great monster is damn good it was
Wonder was awesome great twist ooh I
can't wait
um
[Music]
when's your next stream Beth in your
dreams
oh snap I just I just sound like I have
indigestion is why the indigestion
button oh you know what I bet if I look
up at this thing can I yell at that
thing how do I get to yell again oh I
can move this thing all of a sudden Oh
what what the helmet
this is extremely Zelda II do I move it
into light what do we think we do here I
can't really move it this way right
there's only two places I can move it so
I think maybe let's just move it over to
this side right
or maybe you have to move it over so I
can yell at that thing more
[Music]
ah man
mrs. connect to up there anything your
indigestion mu gave you the strength to
move don't walk yeah mmm powerful core I
mean I can almost reach this thing I
guess almost is a relative term I can't
reach it at all uh that's right to here
oh man I just felt like a bossy fifth
grader I did see I did see vomit on the
ledge right here there is ledge fondant
so we know we can get up there somehow
is there something else I can move I
feel like the water the light reflecting
on the water has something to do with
this right there today feels like
there's something going on here the side
of the post oh yeah wait is there vomit
on this side ah there's vomit right here
guys we found more vomit vomit Lidge
thanks for a bunch of people listen
thank you for helping us with the bobbin
who they would think that whoever came
and vomited on all these ledges really
helped us out and I appreciate it
you know it must have had some bad milk
yeah thank you whoever had indigestion
and threw up on those ledges because
it's that would be how do you even do
this how would you even find what to do
in this game oh here we go I will say in
the witness this game in the witness
like it wouldn't show you where to stand
you would just see the stuff and have to
figure it out but you know I appreciate
it
now I gotta go move too dumb thing over
and the other thing very acidic vomit
yes this is true
make sure it's right uh anyone do it
look around this area I know actually
probably like up here
oh I see just supposed to put it where
they season the end they're perfect
maybe there's a point in this game where
it doesn't tell you how to do it maybe
this is just that we did just start this
games
yeah give it to me yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're seeing Tetris it's the testers
Tetris effect that vomit I see a lot of
seagulls ha ha ha ha
you know what to che maybe the seagulls
are actually pooping on everything
helping us anyway there's like oh well
show Murr to go ridiculous ridiculous Oh
guys we have 8 more minutes I think
we're going to take one more Corgi break
before we're done actually you know what
will end on corgis why don't we head
down some queries how does that sound of
Miley trying to find a new 8 more
minutes till our last Corgi break of the
day yeah it's just we're doing a public
service it's hump day you know maybe
some people aren't having a great week
ooh
mm-hmm what's in here
I always wonder like who made these
temples and who is like making all this
pushes through here nope
who made these temples and why do they
leave all these blocks around I'm always
curious about that there's a great if
you've seen that movie Galaxy Quest
there's really there's a fun moment in
that movie where Galaxy Quest is quite
great because it's about a cast of a
show a lot like it's like Star Trek in
like the 70s and then you know TV
signals were beamed out into the galaxy
and so aliens think that they're real
and they build this ship and come to
earth and ask the cast of Galaxy Quest
to help them to save them against these
other aliens and at one point you know
they've built the aliens have built the
ship to the specifications that they saw
in the TV show but it's all fake and
crazy and you know there was one episode
in the galaxy quest TV show where they
had to go by these swinging blades or
whatever in this engine room and so the
aliens made that it's a long way to go
for a metaphor but all I'm saying is who
made these temples and what's the deal
gotta go this way
no one would make a temple like this it
doesn't make any sense
this is interesting so where's our third
piece oh wait there's a piece over here
[Music]
oh wait we're supposed to look the other
way baby I got it
I'll the old DW fake-out all right fair
enough
[Music]
does kind of tell you where to put it
which is a little lame yeah
then again I'm stupid so maybe it's a
good thing yeah we need it I definitely
need it
oh wait is this thing turn around
somehow oh yes it does here we go here
we go like how is this how who's gonna
make a temple that's gonna have this you
know okay like why would you make a
temple with this that doesn't make any
sense and that's you're just being kind
of a dick about the whole thing
great yep we got to find we got to get
this broken piece up here man mmm how do
we do that
this thing doesn't move right oh my god
you guys I'm really excited about the
end of the stream today I think we're
gonna get some pretty cool it's gonna be
pretty dough it's are a mirror or
something
let's see here well we know we can turn
the thing
can I was like the Facebook end yeah it
does look like the Facebook F that's
true
maybe this is what Zuckerberg house look
like yeah that's what I was thinking for
this was designed by look for is like
Westworld oh yeah be nice is that for
you now what happened is the I guess we
should talk about the underworld
although you should watch that but like
it's crazy it's a crazy ending it's
great uh did she find the maze I can't
remember and don't tell me we'll talk
about it after this amazing not for
amazes not for the stream guys amazed
it's not for you yeah there everything
is in it they make it too easy and I get
yeah god this is so easy cut to me like
just stuck on this forever
oh hi Taiwan I will say this game has
won me over though once we got past the
cliff part we found the vines it was
dope just a nice place to hang out yeah
it's just doing anything for anybody
this is helping anybody anything nope
I think we need to learn a new thing you
know like how to move this dumb thing or
something there's a new thing you have
to learn um
oh that's O'Malley's email I was like
what is that Oh got a facebook chat we
why's Beth in the facebook chat guys
this is how I play every game I just
play I just do the same thing over and
over until I something occurs to me that
will March finder app have Corgi marches
oh yes absolutely little link if you
guys miss more corgis the March finder
sketch Monday yeah all right well this
is a thing here right maybe there's
something inside that we missed how do
we get the Facebook app to match up with
the other thing that's my question
listen this game is about corgis and
Facebook yeah everybody knows everybody
knows is a Facebook or Union we're
clearly close here
I don't wait a second it's telling me to
oh wait a second ah so now what now it's
a different sit what does that even do
maybe it open up something inside we go
back inside and see what's up did it
open up that other dumb area so I can
push this stupid block this way see
there's something going on here man got
to figure this thing out this is
probably the typical like oh it's gonna
take me 19 things to do then I come back
to that situation
ah Sergey I think there I think there
might be a plot I'm not quite sure what
it is yet so far it's free the corgis oh
look oh look see it joined onto this
thing ah got it
see we learned a thing now you can join
the thing unto the other thing guys
we're learning things you know I also
want one thing I'm really love about
puzzlers is it kind of teaches you
without words or language how did solve
things you know like it like that's kind
of what miss did like they're kind of
teaches you a new language which is cool
because that's not that's not really
something you get to do day to day oh
yeah you know when you're oh the Fox is
back I mean the core you sorry Corgi is
love Corgi is life here we go oh hey and
there's a person back over there there's
a person down there again I can't just
jump down oh wait I can't just jump down
here we go we're gonna go through this
doorway to end the stream guys here we
go
they disappeared again we're looking for
like our dad or something or just going
to be like a Prince of Persia situation
where it's like us but in the future
it's your pops dude hold wait up dude
wait up bro it's a little horror
movie-esque
oh look at this
ah see we are learning guys exactly
all hail the keyhole it's nothing
related to MIT's just a random story
okay fair enough
pretty cool alright guys I think that's
gonna do it for day stream thank you all
for joining us we hope you had a great
time mixer
hello mixer hello Facebook and of course
YouTube at which we love you guys as
well uh make sure to watch the show
tonight who's on the show again
Nick Offerman Oh Nick Offerman Nicholas
offer many know miss Ron Swanson of
course we have uh the mummy Annabelle
wallet Annabelle Wallis from the mummy
and Marc Norman I stayed at my
government so there you go ah and make
sure to tune in next Wednesday right
back here at stream Coco and now we will
leave this game has been Ryan this is
about Brosky Jason O'Malley creeper in
the corner and we will see you guys next
week enjoy this amazing Corgi moment
you